this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbuster
summer
are you ready for some big budget sci-fi
with huge explosions
crazy shootouts
and killer aliens
one 90s film had the courage to give you
all that
plus be really horny thank you so much
really super horny like to take a few
pictures
the archives
the fifth element welcome
to the future of america a land full of
smoking
toplessness and rude waiters to the
point where you just know this movie was
made by a bunch of french
tendu a huge ball of evil is on its way
and the only way to stop it is to gather
the power stones of earth
air fire and water to summon
captain planet the power
is yours i mean this girl
illumina
that whole thing's your name huh meet
lilu a living weapon who has to be
turned on
before she turns on and the best man for
that job
is corbin dallas the ultimate balance of
bruce willis giving a sh
and bruce willis not giving a shout
about the movie he's currently in
sir are you classified as human uh
negative i am a meat popsicle
she might be the supreme being but this
right here it's perfect bruise
anybody else want to negotiate welcome
back to the party pal
love you frosty tips by the way but
they're not the only guardians of this
galaxy
thrill at ancient aliens with the land
speed of a box turtle
please hurry you still have time
jedi school dropouts who won't hesitate
to knock you out and steal your identity
mr dallas uh yeah
a xenomorph who went to juilliard
and a government that is clearly no
holds barred
but at the head of the parade is ruby
rod a literal [ __ ]
who love him or hate him predicted live
streaming in podcasts and will go down
in history
as the best screamer in sci-fi
and also one of the only people to go
down in sci-fi
i don't want one position i want all
positions
personally i think chris tucker killed
it but this is the role that prince was
born to play
the clock is ticking and that giant evil
space net is on a collision course with
earth
heralding its arrival with a power of
ooze
and this testicle has help on the inside
john batiste emanuel zorg
he's a bad guy with the power of
capitalism
they wondered if it'd be possible to
fire five hundred thousand fire one
million
a gun that shoots all the things
and the yelling range of a fired up gary
oldman
zero stones zero crates
man i can't wait to see him fight bruce
willis in a climactic battle
wait did the hero and villain never even
meet each other in this movie what
no not even allowed to happen so if
you're a fan of star wars classic hero's
journey
where a young man destined for greatness
answers the call to action
and accepts his fate to defeat an empire
strap
in as fifth element takes you on the
heroes midlife crisis
where a middle-aged man who hates his
job answers the call to go on a cruise
and accepts his fate to hook up with a
lady have his age who doesn't speak
english
lilu dallas multipass in depending on
who you ask
either one of the best or the worst
sci-fi films of the 90s
but is indisputably one of the weirdest
and is the most fun of luke bisson's
childlike traumatized but badass lady
sex object series
huh but no matter how you feel about it
one thing
is for certain you'll never forget what
the movie is called
fifth element the fifth element
fifth element the fifth element fifth
element
story buzz light beer
what if god was one of us chris
talked darth bezos hold me closer tiny
lister
[Music]
[Applause]
blue beyonce the rude beehive
lessons about consent you're right
you're right i shouldn't have done that
i shouldn't have done that the present
day nypd
and this mugger who wears a picture of
corbin's hallway on his head to trick
him
no joke here we just really like the guy
i hope that dance catches on blade
runner
the zf1 has got nothing on the greatest
90s toy of all time the eliminator ts7
[Music]
ice cube system
hell yeah hey screen junkies
want more fifth element then click left
for 100 more things we love about this
weird movie
and click right to hang out with screen
junkies universe our daily morning show
thank you for bringing back blockbuster
summer
let your conscience be your guide black
lives matter